you know I actually took this question
from Twitter and I answered the question
in one word you've lived a life
dominated by doubt and fear how do you
step into bravery step that's that's how
you step into bravery step take the step
step aggressively towards your fear and
that that step towards your fear is the
step into bravery because we're scared
of what we don't know and there's only
one way to learn and to know and that is
to confront that fear you have to step
you have to go and this simple action
this simple attitude it answers so many
questions so many questions how do you
get to the gym every day you step you go
how do you how do you change your diet
to step you go how do you overcome fear
of failure fear of success or or fear of
fear itself
step and how do you face the fear of the
unknown step don't wait anymore don't
think anymore don't plan anymore don't
contemplate anymore
don't make any more excuses or
justifications don't rationalize
anything else no no and no instead
be aggressive take action now and what
is the first action that you need to
take what's the first step you need to
take the first step you need to take is
just that step